we're gonna spend some time today
looking at a new interview that Donald
Trump gave to the Washington Post every
time that Trump gives these long-form
interviews to print media outlets it is
a veritable house of horrors is what I
would call it if it seems that Trump is
clueless when he's talking in these
sound bites or when yelling over the
were of his helicopter on the White
House lawn that is nothing compared to
what happens when Trump actually sits
down for a longer interview with print
media who then published transcripts of
what Donald Trump says and Donald Trump
gave one of these interviews to The
Washington Post he sat down with Josh
Dawsey and Philip Rucker from the
Washington Post and what I want to do
today is really dig into just a few of
the sections there's really a lot to
look at here to get a sense of it the
way in which it's so much more evident
that the guy has no clue when you let
him talk a little more when you have a
format that allows for follow-up
questions or clarifications and what we
very quickly learn is giving Donald
Trump the opportunity to clarify
actually muddies the water even more it
becomes less clear what he's trying to
say and what he knows so let's just jump
into it and we can talk about some of
these here's a first section okay and
we're putting these up on the screen and
I'll read them to you and we'll discuss
Josh dossie ask Trump this was about
that climate change report that Trump
says he just doesn't believe which is
his own administration's report dossie
says you said yesterday when you were
leaving that you were skeptical of a
climate change report that the
government had done can you just explain
why you're skeptical of that report
Trump says one of the problems that a
lot of people like myself we have very
high levels of intelligence but were not
necessarily such believers it's already
insane okay there is no argument to be
made when the president is being asked
about policy that he's very intelligent
and this has been a hallmark of Trump
since he was just candidate Trump
talking about Wharton and who knows what
else
Trump goes on to say you look at our air
and
water and it's right now at a record
clean that's nonsense gibberish and it's
also not true and then Trump goes on to
say but when you look at China and you
look at parts of Asia and when you look
at South America and when you look at
many other places in this world
including Russia including just many
other places the air is incredibly dirty
okay I mean I guess he's pointing out
that there's pollution all over the
planet but again it has nothing to do
with the believability of his
administration study and he goes on and
says and when you're talking about an
atmosphere oceans are very small and it
blows over and it sails over what on
earth does that mean I I don't I don't
know what he's talking about and then he
goes on to say I mean we take thousands
of tons of garbage off our beaches all
the time that it comes over from Asia it
flows right down the Pacific it flows
and we say where does this come from and
it takes many people to start off with
the hell is this guy talking about okay
I mean he's pointing out that the
currents and the Pacific Ocean bring
some trash over from Asia to the west
coast of the US that's all true but Pat
does this have anything to do with the
study does this have anything to do with
the question Trump was asked which was
why don't you believe your own
administration study saying that there's
currents in the ocean that doesn't mean
anything yet all rambling but by the
time you get to the end of it you almost
forget what the question was and maybe
that's why it's so effective for him
yeah and that's why it's often really
good to actually have a sit-down print
interview with Trump because then he
continues on this issue okay let's put
up the next part of his answer which
makes just as little sense Trump says
number two if you go back and if you
look at articles they talked about
global freezing they talked about at
some point the planet could have freeze
to death and then it's going to die of
heat exhaustion what the hell is he
talking about right there is movement in
the atmosphere there's no question as to
whether or not it's man-made and whether
or not the effects that you're talking
about are there I don't see it not
nearly like it is he doesn't see
it's nearly like it is isn't he's saying
he doesn't see it the way it actually is
I don't see it not nearly like it is he
goes on to say do we want clean water
absolutely do we want clean air to
breathe absolutely the fire in
California where I was if you looked at
the floor the floor of the fire they
have trees that were fallen they did no
forest management no forints maintenance
and you can light you can take a match
like this and light a trunk when that
thing is laying there for more than 14
or 15 months and it's a massive problem
in California so that that is also
gibberish but it actually refers to a
particular debunked notion that the
fires in California are because of poor
forest management it's wrong I mean it's
just it what he said there is wrong on
the facts on everything and then again
Trump continuing with the lies talking
about climate change saying quote Josh
you go to other places where they have
denser trees it's more dense where the
trees are more flammable they don't have
forest fires like this because they
maintain and it was very interesting I
was watching the firemen and they're
raking brush you know the tumbleweed and
brush and all this stuff that's growing
underneath it's on fire and they're
raking it working so hard and they're
raking all this stuff if that was raked
in the beginning there'd be nothing to
catch on fire it's very interesting to
see a lot of the trees they look
tremendous
they took tremendous burn at the bottom
but they didn't catch on fire the bottom
is all burned but they didn't catch on
fire because they sucked the water they
were wet you need forest management and
they don't have it so again this is if
you are just wondering is he coming up
with this stuff all on his own
he's not this is something he got from a
misunderstanding of what Finland does
and even Finland has now said what Trump
is saying we're doing is not actually
what we're doing like it it's just all
lies Pat and I feel as though when you
look at the transcript it's more obvious
that he's clueless than when he yells
over his helicopter but I still think
many people aren't getting the the utter
ignorance of what he's saying here and
it's especially strange because he used
all of these talking points last week
and they were thoroughly debunked by a
number of news outlets
so a week later to rehash them as if
they haven't been debunked that just
shows that he's not keeping up to date
on all of the the news stories out there
and he's doing basically the same thing
with the Jamaal Khashoggi killing where
if you've been watching our show you
know that on the Jamaal khashoggi
killing Trump's priority has been not
freedom of the press and protecting a
free press not human rights not holding
people accountable but his priority has
been to defend Saudi Arabia over saying
he believes them over our own
intelligence agencies check out this
part of the transcript dossie says mr.
president your national security team is
going to the hill tomorrow to brief
senators on Saudi Arabia and Jamal
khashoggi I've heard from Senator Graham
who I know you were with yesterday and
others that they want stronger
punishment on Saudi Arabia tougher
sanctions do you want them to impose
that or do you think that would be
deleterious to our and Trump interrupts
and says I'm gonna listen to what they
say they're all friends of mine and I
get along with them great this is this
is Trump okay
who's friends with him Trump wants to be
liked he wants to be friends with people
rather than just doing the right thing
and he goes on and he says I'm going to
certainly listen to what they have to
say Josh in the end though they're
spending massive amounts of billions of
dollars if you look at Iran and what
they do this is a key point and you look
at many other countries I don't have to
embarrass other countries by saying it
if you look at what they do
to rough part of the world it's a
dangerous rough part of the world but
they've been a great ally without them
Israel would be in a lot more trouble we
need to have a counterbalance on Iran I
know him I know him well the crown
prince and by the way never did business
with them never intend to do business
with them that's a lie of course and
then he goes on so we get we can sort of
skip the the rest of it here here are
the important things to take away from
that I don't even know how to explain
this because it's so insane even though
it was said initially that Jamal
khashoggi started having trouble when he
wrote articles critical of Saudi
Arabia's action in Yemen I told you on
Mondays show that actually
shogi started to be targeted when he was
critical of Donald Trump's position on
Iran right after the 2016 election why
is that the case it's because Trump's
position on Iran is good for Saudi
Arabia this unilateral pulling out of
the Iran deal Khashoggi wrote how that's
a bad idea in general and Saudi Arabia
didn't like that and Donald Trump didn't
like that so remember that officially
nothing about Khashoggi has to do with
Iran Trump is asked about Khashoggi in
an interview and he brings up Iran
unprovoked which confirms that yes it
actually has much more to do with the
specific ideas that Khashoggi was
putting out there that Donald Trump
seems indifferent or uncaring
about actually making sure that the
people who killed this guy are held
accountable it's stunning
that Donald Trump is unprovoked
mentioning Iran when that's what we
suspect we suspect that actually
Khashoggi got negative attention from
Saudi Arabia and potentially from the
Trump administration is what we're now
speculating because of what he was
saying about Iran and Trump's trade up
brings it up this is truly despotic
and dangerous and we don't push this guy
we might never actually get his real
feelings about some of these issues
that's why these written interviews are
so important and that there's one other
part I was going to put up for you that
we won't it's about tariffs Trump again
brought up this idea that the tariffs
increase the tariffs increase revenue
for the United States which is of course
totally absurd the tariffs increased
revenue for the tariffs country and they
increase costs for the United States of
America rambling egotistical delusional
ignorance and these are the incoherent
rants of someone who's not fit to no
insult to gym managers Trump's not fit
to manage a local gym nevermind the
economy of the United
states of america send me your thoughts
we are on twitter at david pakman show
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman I look
forward to hearing from you